i can totally see why in the 50s
this was and 60s actually some
psychedelics
were already legal in a medical setting
against depression whatever but back
then depression was not a big thing so i
was like
it must be that i was very sure actually
people would work on it now because this
was so
powerful and then actually for two years
i was looking around are there any
companies i can invest in
there weren't and then i did it myself
i'm dave rubin and we're mixing it up a
bit today we're gonna shift
from politics hallelujah we're gonna be
talking about
crypto about longevity and of course
about magic mushrooms
joining me is the founder of iperon
investment group a board member of the
hayek institute
and the founder of the angermeier policy
and innovation forum
christian angermeier welcome to the
reuben report hi dave uh
pleasure to be here it's good to be with
you you know you were one of like
10 people that i would occasionally
check in with
in the last year and a half to make some
sense of the world and talk about covet
and lockdowns and
science and fact and all that stuff so
i'm going to just start you broadly here
where are we at in the world right now
where are we
well uh we let's start there i'm
vaccinated so i'm
pro vaccination if that is this it seems
still to be a big debate in the u.s
always when i post something i get a lot
of hate and love and whatever
but in generally like if we we discussed
it before like if we take it one level
higher one of my my um
my ideas or my fuses that sort of the
whole world is
kind of going into or is already in a
mental health crisis meaning it's really
the mental health crisis in terms of
really like
what we at the moment define as mental
health crisis like depression anxiety
addiction so all of
opioid addiction like all of these
numbers are
skyrocketing but i think we have
way more issues we as
a sort of planet or humanity is going
through mentally
which we have not defined yet
as a as a real disease so my so if you
talk to so many people they
feel literally they can't even express
it because there is no word for it like
yeah but like like that some somewhere i
think
the majority of people feels that the
world is going in a direction
which a doesn't make sense for them so
they can't understand
a lot of things anymore and b they
subconsciously and that's even worse
no there might be no place for them
in the world let's say we the tech elite
is building so i'm always when i
i have these literally every time i
whenever we do a new investment and i'm
telling my friends like we just did a
investment in a brain computer interface
company
and so my vision is and i'm super
excited about it that in 10 years 15
years
all of us gonna have brain implants yeah
brain computer
implants and and then we can sort of do
things like from telepathy to
communicating without any device
being the sky is the limit what you can
do if our brain is directly into a
computer
i think it's fascinating and always when
i talk to friends of mine
i realize how deeply terrifying that is
for them
yeah and it's just one example so what
i'm thinking is that i'm coming back why
are you saying that in terms of covet
so so i'm thinking like again the world
it makes less and less sense for people
at the same time they
they don't feel sort of at home where
they see they don't have a place
and that frightens them yeah and fear
unfortunately
brings out the worst in us yeah so and
fear
and trauma is also one of the underlying
root cases for mental health issues
so so i think like we all have this
collective
mental health issue um again for
a disease we don't have a name for yet
it could be like i
don't have one like it's not a good
short name but like being afraid of a
future or
don't feeling at home in the world
anymore so the outcome is though
that we become extremely tribal because
we
try to find um like refuge or like a
home or like stability in a world of
permanent unstability and it's not going
to change
the world in 15 years or 10 years will
be so different
meaning never ever we had we have a
change which was happening so quickly
so and we so we resort in this tribalism
which practically makes
also every now coming back to covid
every rational discussion
obsolete meaning we completely lost the
ability i think to be
in the middle of something like it's
always like in here i mean we had all
these discussions like
both sides like the in america the
republicans or the right wing the left
wing like
yeah it's insane and i think there is a
more
underlying reason which is the one i
just described yeah so that's why i
wanted to have you on because i've been
talking about on the show for a while
that it seems like we're at the end of
one world and there's a new world on the
horizon but but people are worried about
it we know about all the mental health
stuff
but you were kind of in the the
psychedelic game before
all of this was happening like you
you've been thinking about how do we
make
people happier and less
depressed and with less anxiety and all
that stuff
for quite some time when did you get
interested in that um
i got interested i can tell you exactly
in 2014
when i had my first own magic mushroom
trip
which was in a country where it's legal
which was
they always have to say the disclaimer
was that holland where where was that
what which country was that that was
holland you know it was actually on a
really a tiny island it's called kanwan
in the caribbean
yeah so it's legal or not classified in
most countries in the caribbean latin
america
and actually in the netherlands like
that's the uh the interesting part
and so and by the way
because maybe i come to this in a point
that i think
psychedelics should be taken in a
medical context or at least with a guide
so i had a very good shaman
doing it with me but like uh just for
the ones
watching now and saying jesus he's a
druggie like
i always was extremely comfortable to
talk about it because
i am the least druggy person you ever
would have ever met like i have never
drank alcohol ever in my whole life
i have never smoked a cigarette never
smoked a joint actually never did
anything else like i drank um
coffee when i was 28 for the first time
christian and
not coffee oh now i like coffee is okay
now but what i want to say so i came
very virgin to that whole
thing and then it was hands down
the single most meaningful and important
and life enriching thing i've ever done
in my whole life full stop nothing
really comes close
and i have to say i was already a very
happy person
yeah so and immediately after that i was
like okay if it can do
this to me yeah a happy person
i can totally see why in the 50s
this was in 60s actually some
psychedelics
were already legal in a medical setting
against depression whatever but back
then depression was not a big thing so i
was like
it must be that i was very sure actually
people would work on it now
because this was so powerful and then
actually for two years i was looking
around are there any companies i can
invest in
there weren't and then i did it myself
right so what's that like when you're
like all right i'm gonna be the magic
mushroom guy and i should tell you
i i've done magic mushrooms many times
and it's b it's been a while but
i've always loved doing it i never had a
bad effect i wasn't
depressed after anything if anything
it's exactly what you're saying it sort
of
elevates the good stuff but but sort of
what i think is interesting about you
also
is that you're you're basically but i
don't want to put words in your mouth
you're basically politically a
conservative
and i think it's kind of there's like
this dichotomy between wait a minute
he's a conservative
but also he's the magic mushroom guy i
sort of say that's what the new
sort of conservative thing is so can you
talk a little bit about that and then
how you went ahead and said okay we're
going to make
this into a business all right so first
of all what beni
totally fine but sorry i actually would
say i'm rational like
and i'm i'm no and it's like i think one
of the big problems
is already that i think we're still
using terms
which don't fit in our time anymore
there should be no left and right
because
left and right i always tell my friends
who are like in germany and the social
democrats are like you were
there i tell my friends look you should
have gone home in the 80s because
you won yeah you really if a hundred
years back
there were a real issue for the working
class yeah so then
someone you reached everything you
should have reinvented yourself finally
but that's another talk right finding
actually there would be a place for real
social in a positive manner no socialist
in
english always have these negative we
call it social democracy like
center socialist because i think never
ever then
in the last 60 years then today the
working class has a real issue because
their jobs gonna vanish all of them
hundred percent
yeah yeah this is what tucker is a
politician i would take that
as my thing how can i help um
the real working class how can i how can
how can we
create and this comes back to my worry
about
the mental health state we have to
create a world
where we all have a place because let me
take one analogy which is not a nice one
but to sort of paint a negative picture
because we had all of that like 100 if i
so i love history
like and if you if you if you i searched
for like a time
which is sort of similar to ours i know
history never repeats but rhymes like
so but like if you go in the time 1850
to 1910 1915 there are so many parallels
the elites were completely tech savvy
you had julverand
the author he was writing actually about
going to the moon
about flying to the stars about going uh
undersea you had the
people forget that it was the time of
the the world fair in paris actually
this was the eiffel tower was built as a
symbol
of technological uh innovation so there
was the biggest elevator in eiffel tower
you had all these amazing books writing
about uh
actually future like fantasy but it
became real like actually
anyway so you had these enormous
optimism you had berlin by the way
being an incredibly liberal city like
gay rights like party like the elite
was in a collective
happiness yeah but 95 of the people were
most likely thinking you're [ __ ]
crazy
because they were all farmers yeah and
was it actually was it was the dawn
so we were moving from an agrarian
culture right korean society
into the industrial age that was this
was the evening or
the eve so the the eve of the the
industrial age yeah so but unfortunately
in that industrial age
a lot of the people who were needed in
the
in the agrarian age were redundant so
again like the same like today very much
happening but had no place in that
future
so what did the people do they invented
kind of nationalism and they invented
communism
because that was the tribes they were
resorting to
yeah to actually sort of uh get a little
bit of
uh healing from the anxiety and the fear
and that actually gave the world to
world wars so
so my my fear is that if we're not
finding a way
to take 100 of humanity
with us us i mean like the tech elite
who says hey we're gonna go to mars and
by the way i do think we're gonna go to
mars like
yeah but like if we don't take all the
people with us
yeah it's gonna end very badly because i
can say it again like fear brings out
the worst in that and that comes them
back to psychedelics
because wait let's pause let's pause for
one second then we'll get into the
psychedelics part because
i love this so are are you shocked how
the the tech elite
seemed to hate the regular person like
if you if you ask the regular person
like what do you think the
the head of twitter or facebook or all
these people think about you they think
oh they want to censor us they don't
want us to
speak freely they want to own our data
and all of that stuff
so you're trying to basically rectify
that
well so what do you think that the
ordinary people hate the tech people or
the other way around
i think it's a little i think it's a
little bit of both but i consider myself
more of the regular person i think the
average person
thinks that the big tech people just
basically
you know think that their fodder for
whatever their algorithms want
and however they can make money
something like that
well meaning one other theory and i'm
copying that what i'm saying now you can
stop by original thought but like
one of the things what uh juwal harari
yeah
sort of uh coined was this idea that
if again if if humanity
i don't wanna say goes bad because i
still don't know i have not i have not
reached the conclusion if it's like
good or bad or neutral but it could be
hindsight like in 100 or 200 years we
might look at this time and say
we have split up in two species because
you have
a part of the humanity who says hey
bring it on
let's fly to mars and by the way one
very simple fact if you want to go to
mars
we're gonna need to change our body
because our body is not made
for not even mars travel not to talk
about space travel
yeah you die of cancer within some weeks
yeah so
if we want to go to mars it's not just
going to mars we're going to have to
modify
and nobody's talking about that but i
think everybody knows it right so that's
that's the whole transhumanism movement
basically exactly so and by the way and
you and it's gonna happen because the
we already have it you have a heart if
you have a stent i think it's called
english like
yeah so it is already a mini
technological intervention like
so and somehow we get comfortable like
and we're going to get more and more and
more
but there might be a part of the
humanity who says this is not for me
yeah i don't want to merge with machines
and again it sounds already so
sci-fi but it's gonna gradually happen
so so so humanity might split into
species and in 50 years hundred years
we're going to look back and say well
that so and that's already like sort of
in a mini way happening now because you
have these one part of humanity who
wants
sort of go wider further
the sky's the limit like let's bring it
on and then you have and what i said
like
the other part who maybe doesn't really
it i don't want to say intellectually
because this sounds uh
degrading but i just like let's take a
positive example and i really mean it
positive and sorry by the way i'm not an
english speaker so
yeah so you're doing it a lot of
politically correctness things because i
always can say i didn't mean it that way
um so now i take a bus driver so he or
she
maybe can't explain you how autonomous
driving works
yeah but somehow i think humans always
have a very good gut feeling so as a
collective we're actually pretty smart
and somehow that bus driver knows
this is not going in the right direction
i'm not going to be a bus driver in 10
years yeah
and and and that again makes him maybe
resent the people
yeah so again it comes back we need to
sort of take him
or her or whatever like on this sort of
thing okay so now i'm gonna
now link that to psychedelics for me so
no so that
many first of all i don't have an answer
on that like fully like because i just
think like
but i i think the bigger fear what i
have is that we don't even discuss the
problem we discuss so many [ __ ]
stuff
can i say you can say anyway
so no but like this is like i think this
is your point yeah this is the point of
a lot of friends we have that
a lot of discussions if you see the real
issue
like or the real problems yeah a lot of
discussions are
really observed because they're like why
don't but again
i see rather through the lens that i'm
like okay i understand why the people
have this discussion
take all the identity politics
it is again another form of tribalism
how
in the 1850s and following the people
invented
communism so to say and nationalism now
we're inventing
other crazy stuff yeah but it makes us
feel at home
it makes us feel us against the rest of
us so how do psychedelics come into it
so where do i start because it's like
it's very so one thing why i'm always
very
a little bit hesitating not hesitating
like so it's very hard and i have to
describe a psychedelic trip
first yeah i was gonna ask you please
and in a certain way it's extremely
let's call it spiritual
you could all say religious you could
say so the thing is it's very
mystical yeah and practically every word
our language is not made
to this it's really out the worldly you
sort of leave the realm of
of of something and go to another one so
so what i want to say is like the
language is not so
easy this is why by the way most
religions are based on psychedelics
provenly including christianity and this
is why they all use these pictures and
describe
things like the burning chair which or
chariot which goes in the air whatever
because they can't put
actually their experience really in
words because there are no words to
describe a psychic director that's
first yeah so and if i do it then i need
to use religious terms
and the problem is that religious terms
in our world especially are incredibly
loaded so if i use the word soul
then you might think or might think
about
and then and i do and another person
either
god whatever so i try to stay as neutral
and try
for the viewers to make a little bit of
an abstraction and don't
think necessarily in the narrow terms of
any religion but in a wider meaning so
when you do psychedelics
you you have a part in your brain which
constitutes your ego and this
part is
depending which psychedelic you take is
either really reduced to zero
or at least heavily regulated down so
it's called default mode mechanism
so practically in this part of the brain
there is something
which tells you you are dave and this is
christian
we have a different history you have all
the happiness you received you have all
the pains all the scars
everything which makes dave dave is
there yeah and that goes down
again very downward or to zero and
interesting in the same moment
you doing that something else is
emerging
or at least it's hurt maybe it's always
there philosophically but
you realize it again hear it see it feel
it
and now we can call it a soul we can
call that uh
in a voice we can call that your
subconsciousness yeah
it must not necessarily i'm not saying
it proves by the way that god is there
that's another discussion
yeah but but that is definitely 100 of
the people have
and this sort of soul um
and uh sort of universal
feeling gives you a lot of insights
so and if i try a little bit to make the
main ones the first one is
which is by the way super important i
think for everybody is um
it shows you who you really are
and what you really want so it might
sound it's a simple question
but most people don't either don't know
or if they know they are afraid of
accepting it
in any form it can be simple stuff i had
people who took psychedelics who were
extremely wealthy and realized the only
thing i want to spend more time with my
family but i didn't dare to
say it because i'm running this big
corporation or whatsoever anyway
so so it's it's it sounds by the way
everything i tell you about psychedelics
sometimes sounds super simple because
you could read it in every
um dpek chopra book yeah
but you you uh you perceive it on a
level
that it's an absolute truth you come out
of it and like okay i realize now what i
want and i'm gonna change my life
in a way that i'm happy yeah so that is
one
one big part is that sort of realization
of your true self
of your also the negatives
also the painful one so it's incredibly
trauma
healing which is by the way and i have
to say
more often like a trip must not be
nice it's not a party trip it's nothing
you want to do
at a disco yeah so it can be extremely
sick or extremely cleansing yeah
but you're always going to feel better
after yeah and i actually had uh
very colloquially we say bad trips
but i like the word more challenging
trips but they were actually the nicest
or the best ones not the nicest one of
the best ones
because they gave me so much because i
learned so much about
again fears whatever which you're trying
to hide very
somewhere yeah and you dissolve them
anyway so that's one thing and the
second big thing
what also happens is
you feel connected to nature
and other humans in a way you can't
describe and one
other form so so there are several
sources of mental health issues if i've
been
oversimplified the one i already said is
fear and trauma
yeah and the other one is lost
connections a lot of people
feel disconnected from everything from
the world from
from people whatever and psychedelics
bring back
that enormous sort of love for
the creation if i want to know it's like
for humans animals this is why by the
way
this is why a lot of people go vegan
after that or at least say i want to be
more responsible towards my
environment and then the third part is
very interesting and that is
maybe at least all of these things are
very i think
helping in what i said to de-traumatize
the world
um the third one is in the weeks after
in a very simplified way your brain is
literally growing a bit we call that
neuroplasticity
um so which helps you
on the one side to develop habits or to
get rid of habits so it's extremely
helpful if you want to get often
addiction
stuff like that but also if you look at
brains after
the people seem to be more creative
yeah and also more
again it's very more open for the world
and i think what we all have to have
to go into this time with the same
mental health
is like this or like this sort of
the future is gonna be fine like we just
need to find out
so but if you tell that a 60 year old
even leave away whatever the job is like
some so unfortunately if you look at the
brain
people always think of the aging of the
body but our brain round about when
you're 30
is starting to age not just in a sort of
mental capacity that you're losing
gradually a little bit like
but also you're literally closing down
like if you go like in an old people's
home
why do people not make friends you would
say they have time they have the whole
day they should make a lot of friends
yeah
you literally can't your brain is not
wired anymore
so you make your friends in your 20s
yeah when you're open when so so really
for example all my friends i have but i
actually i make new friends all the time
because i think i'm always i don't know
psychedelics like
so psychedelic facts that chris we
became friends in the last two years now
i don't know if you were tripping at the
time but
yeah so so no so well honestly like so
so you get back this sort of
openness for the world yeah and so
yeah so these three things if i look at
what we need a
we need to have the discussion that we
let's say that elite or we as the world
we need to offer
a world where these people i said like
the sort of the lower level jobs
where we find new jobs for them but at
the same time we need to make sure that
they want it by the way so
and again telling a 60 year old
look you know what you go back to
university even if he mentally
if he intellectually can he doesn't have
that
impetus anymore with 60. however he
could have it maybe
yeah uh with uh psychedelics right now
it's like it's like telling
it's like telling a journalist to learn
to code i guess that's a
a big problem maybe yeah maybe if you uh
get a little bit of help
and by the way one many example it
becomes not too esoteric where
the uk as the first country i think the
first country
recognized loneliness as a disease
um and especially in old people
and it's literally by the way if you
look at the health data of people who
are lonely at any age
their health is dramatically uh
getting worse because we're pack animals
so if we are alone our stress level goes
up permanently with so because we get
depressive which is again depression has
an impact on our immune system so there
is a
really a downward spiral so so
they're not saying yet that depression
should be sorry that uh
that loneliness should be treated with
psychedelics but the first step is
always to
speak it out and say okay loneliness is
a disease because now we can start going
to the
regulators and saying hey maybe we can
prove you
in a proper clinical study that
psychedelics also might heal not just
depression what we are about to prove
but like also loneliness and stuff like
that and
and i think again coming back to the
beginning there will be some when
a disease again we need a cool name for
it or cool but but like
which is that a fear of the future yeah
and
then and and again then once we have
named it
we can maybe run clinical trials and we
can
bring the ball in motion yeah i mean i'm
so with you on this that i think you're
right people have this sort of
existential dread about the future it
feels like the past is kind of broken
and they're just like oh they can't even
see what is in the future so
for people that know nothing about this
i think they're probably going wait a
minute wait a minute does this guy just
want me to be tripping on mushrooms all
day so what does
what does like an actual uh
way of life look like incorporating some
of this stuff like
are people just micro dosing all day
long so micros is uh
okay let's leave the mic because it's a
complex answer like let's stay with
what what we are doing so i have a
company just ipod
which is called atai atai
and we have more than 10 new mental
health drugs most of them
psychedelic in development so what we're
doing we're taking actually
either we have a lot of elect what we
call anecdote level so i'm always
careful because like
i know that i had these amazing not just
one trip yeah and i know many friends
but
in a scientific view this is still
anecdotal it's like right christian
at the same time i know to be fair like
there are thousands of reports and
thousands so and some of these drugs
actually interestingly
in the last millennia uh in in the last
century were
legal again or medically available for
depression and stuff like that but it's
sort of old data but what we are doing
we're taking these
anecdotal and partly historic so to say
evidence
and really doing and this is important
very rigorous
really state-of-the-art clinical trials
on the fda
and european um supervision yeah in
order to really prove it at the moment i
have to say
look i do think magic mushrooms
potentially
or or ketamine or ibuka you know all the
psychedelics dmt
5ml dmt yeah so i have to potentially
say because it's
in a sort of scientific way not true but
we're proving it now
once and for all and we are actually
with some of them already in phase two
which is like sort of
pretty advanced for biotech yeah
somewhere a little bit earlier stage
um but sort of i would say within the
next five six years yeah
hopefully some of our drugs will be
approved
so and then this is important they're
gonna be medically available
not for take it home not on prescription
but that you go to your psychotherapist
or your doctor yeah and you do the trip
with him or her which is important
because you need a guide actually when
you look where these drugs coming from
they were used since thousands of years
in
ritualistic shamanistic religious way
so you always had a priest or a shaman
with the disciple
and kind of can say that the
the psychotherapists are the shamans of
our time yeah so but that's important so
we don't we want to have it in this
kind of restricted access not because
i think ultimately big parts of humanity
will sort of benefit from it but it's
very it's a very powerful drug so it's
not that you it's not like a
aspirin you pop it and you find like
again part of the process
is really touching your deepest fears
your
all of that yeah so you have to do it
with a psychotherapist
uh but that's what we want to make
available and i think we are in a good
way of it
yeah this may sound like an amateur
question but is everything that you're
testing right now is it all actually
natural substances or is any of it made
in a lab
um not all of it like so
some of the substances we have in our
portfolio at a tie
are originally nature substances
but in any case may they be natural
originally
or some of them are like take mdma which
is a synthetic drug from the beginning
there's
nature natural anime so both yeah but in
any case
we are just using the synthetic version
because you need to be precise in
quality and dosage so you can't
you will not have homegrown magic
mushrooms
in a hospital with a doctor because you
need an exactly
for a for a patient you want the clean
and perfect version yeah
can you just tell people how people
actually get magic mushrooms because i
remember when i was in college and my
buddy came in and he
well he had a bag of magic mushrooms and
he's like you know we're going to do
these and blah blah blah and then i was
like well where'd they come from and
then he told me and i actually couldn't
believe it
and it's still sort of amazing well
at the moment like first of all like for
all the viewers like in most countries
any form of psychedelics are illegal
which is actually sad
because they weren't in the 50s and 60s
for good reason but like anyway
is what it is we're gonna hopefully make
them medically available
but at the moment i have to say yeah
this is not a medical advice yeah and i
think i made it clear like
yeah you and i did so so they are so
just saying like so but if you if
somebody says at the moment
he or she uses magic mushrooms that
means they grown it themselves like it
is a mushroom like yeah
so and yeah uh in the netherlands you
can grow it and eat it
yourself but in essence it's just a
mushroom that's growing off cow poop
right
yeah well you can grow it at home i grow
it at home in a in a small like
i would say like uh like a greenhouse or
something yeah yeah
yeah but yes in nature they actually
offer not always but
often found on cow poop yeah so not
always but like that's one of the things
their favorite
places and then by the way they grow in
most countries so
this is why also like if you go back
actually most religions are um
are based on psychedelic consumption
and yeah well that's why
that's why i was asking you because not
not to be funny about it growing on cow
poo but it's kind of
it's like metaphysically amazing that
this mushroom that grows on
cow poop basically can cause you to have
a five-hour trip
that could potentially change your life
and when you laid out those three steps
before
i've done it enough in my life to know
that everything you said there was true
you mean it's metaphysically interesting
that it's growing on cowboy i'm just
thinking about it it's an interesting
thing
it's just a little bizarre yeah
but i was just thinking because um it's
the question is um
[Music]
when exactly people are seeing it so i
make i have to phrase it a little bit
like uh
uh vaguely but like we're gonna do a
very big university project
uh with a friend of mine uh whom you
should have on the show if you haven't
like brian rescue who wrote
who worked years because so many people
would say instinctively
if you take psychedelics yeah this is
what moses took jesus told mohammed took
yeah
um and now i have a fatwa no i choking
so um no you're not the first you're not
the first on this show don't worry
that's true but actually shiite you say
so so the iranian side of islam actually
is endorsing
psychedelics as something which brings
you closer to god
and actually interestingly also the a
lot of the orthodox jews and
it's very interesting how that merges
with uh religion so
coming back so because my friend went
out and um
and really researched temples
and graveyards and whatever and tried to
find out literally
proving me what did people eat what do
they have in their stomach what is like
what is the residual in a in a mystical
cup
whatever and this is how he could trace
back most religions provenly
that they were all doing psychedelics
including
early christianity and we actually have
very interesting
conversations with the catholic church
because they saying
kind of inofficially like if this was
the reason which by the way i deeply
believe
this was the reason why an obscure
nichi cult from the east became the
dominating religion
in 300 years meaning this was always i'm
brought up castro lake i was always
thinking like how did that happen
like because like they were people were
killed yeah this is not a fun religion
to be in
like and then my priest always said well
they were so big believers i was like
that's a big belief to get killed like
and and slaughtered whatever but if you
think about it if they
use psychedelics which take away the
fear of death
because you know that there is at least
you
think you know like again religious
discussion for another thing like
there is a afterlife whatever it gives
you a completely different
framework sort of to operate in anyway
so but now like actually the catholic
church is coming back and say if that is
provenly the case that early christians
took
psychedelics we might use it again
because that seems to
lift spirituality up a lot and it does
like and i think
there are already sects like santo
diamond in brazil
is a catholic sect and they use um to
use psychedelics
and i think we need that spirituality
back in our world so i'm a very
my viewers or religion is like whatever
you believe it's definitely healthy for
you uh would you say there's any
specific would you say there's any
specific risks related to all of this
psychedelics
we're kicking the religion conversation
for the next time for a psychedelic
well we we are i have to say like
both legally but also responsibly like
we are about to prove
sort of both the efficacy and the risks
this is why clinical trials are made
so there have been though great studies
over the last 50 years repeatedly which
show that
psychedelics have a very very low risk
profile
so what i would recommend like if the
people are watching now sit in front of
a computer google
is my favorite chart of all like google
david
not chart david and not nutt david is a
is a very
uh famous neuroscientist and very famous
for his uh
research around psychedelics and so he
made a bo he wrote a book
which shows how wrongly society
looks at drugs in any form actually a
lot of
people would say today it's still like
oh my god psychedelics like
and then at the same time they drink a
glass of wine which is pure toxic
yeah so so and he and the essence of his
book is this one chart
where he rates all the legal and illegal
drugs from
alcohol to cocaine to psychedelics
how risky they are and how bad they are
for our
for our body and our mind and then many
i'm spilling now the the secret but like
if you look at the chart you see on the
left you see alcohol as the most risky
drug
actually before heroin yeah and and then
at the very right practically
mini mini risk you see psychedelics so
and that is very scientific but again
we are trying or not trying we are about
to prove that now
in a very proper um uh
clinical fda setting all right well
we're gonna link
to that chart below so people can so
they can see it while while they're
listening to
you what else are you interested in
right now i mentioned longevity
at the top that that seems to be a big
one with all the tech people right now
like can we actually live longer
well i think for sure i mean that's not
even a question like
we gonna live longer yeah because it's
already happening like our life
expectancy is
is sort of uh is going up um
i mean i think like if if i come back to
the optimistic view on the future i
think we're going
in he's amazingly interesting time we
all don't know where it leads us but i
think if we
if we instill back curiosity
and the awe for the wonder of the world
in not just the five percent not just
the one percent but like
the majority of people um that's one
step
and then and then i think once you have
that
so once you have a in general let's call
it neutrally curious outlook
in the future and at the same time if
you're happy and i have this one luck in
life
which which actually is a different
backstory than most people have with
psychedelics because a lot come to
psychedelics because they search healing
that's why i didn't want to do it like i
was like i was always a happy child
since i can remember i have a bad day
but in generally
i like myself because i've said like i'm
a very happy person
and i've also always said i think i'm
not dumb so hence already when i was 12
13 i was like okay
this is kind of a great situation like
don't mess it up by putting any drugs
into your brain like don't touch alcohol
don't do it
because you just can't get worse yeah so
but and so what i was saying like once
you're happy and once you're healthy
yeah and once you're curious about the
future
you want to sort of experience that and
i want to stay here
so now as long as i want so i don't
think we're going to live
forever because forever is a very long
term i do
see the realistic chance that
even you and i because we're not 15
anymore or 10 or 20.
yeah we're like the middle now it's
actually interesting
so i think like the sort of the group in
the middle is 40 to 60.
i think the younger people are i mean if
i talk to my 10 year old
godson then he's gonna be some hundred
years
for sure i'm very sure that we're gonna
push
life expectancy into some hundred years
in the next 30 40 years by the way
very important because a lot of people
then think oh my god
i'm gonna beat hundred like they see
people who are 100 now
right but like so no there is no way
to push life expectancy into some
hundred years
without rejuvenating so it's good for
you so we're gonna
we're gonna be young again when it
happens and we're gonna
live significantly longer yeah
and i think our mind is
not made for eternity so even if we
potentially could live
very very long my expectations is that
we will come to a point
where every one of us at this point
might be completely different some
people might say
hey i had enough like i had enough
christmases i had enough
birthdays i want to go now on my own
terms but i think that's the ultimate
because ultimately i'm not even
conservative kind of libertarian like
i want to mind my own business and i
want everybody else to mind their own
business yeah
and i also want to want to decide my own
time of death so to say when i had
enough when i'm
not interested in the world anymore i do
hope that with psychedelics
that's gonna come very late and i'm
gonna enjoy
that for a long time but longevity is a
long story short that we have we have
several companies the two big ones are
cambrian
and rijuveron where we sort of really
try
to to cutting edge drug development like
four things which
sort of make us really live
significantly
it's going longer yeah 10 years you're
going to see
again coming always back the next 10
years earlier than people think
gotta be so world-changing in many
ways uh we just need to look forward to
it
yeah give me one more thing that's
really on your mind at the moment you
want to go
crypto you want to go somewhere else as
we get as we get to the future that's
not depressing because that's that's
what i want my audience to see that it
it's not depressing i know it's sort of
it's painful at the moment but it's not
depressing maybe one thing
it's you're the first one i'm talking
about because i'm formulating it myself
so it might be so uh
i try to get it across so it's about so
we're living in these money printing
um spree yeah and
i think one idea i have is like
most people would say because it's
traditional economics tells you that
it's not going to end well
yeah and we have all the with all the
sort of
um all the consequences like if you talk
about an asset price bubble
uh or at least asset price inflation any
real inflation
maybe uh the wealth cap so there's a lot
of things which are associated with
money printing so it could be though
that it's the most important thing we
can do at the moment
for one reason like if i look at the
world what we haven't talked about yet
is
is sort of the the competition
of economic and political systems
so and practically you have three
relevant players
forgive me russia like it's europe it's
the us
and it's china yeah and it's it's
actually with
some money obviously us and china is a
is a very big difference
europe and the us is is a little bit
less so
but we are all three are different yeah
and
i think what politicians were used to
are
is that in in the old world of economic
linear growth in the 50s and 60s 70s
whenever
a country was falling behind
think about germany by the way in like
around 2000
we were we were called the sick man of
europe and then the german economy
took up again like so in the old days
countries could underperform
relatively to other countries for a
while and then they got their [ __ ]
together and then
sort of they caught up because it was
possible to catch up
in a world of linear growth so we now
and by the way i have this theory of a
very very
high level communist party member so
it's this was like okay
they they really thought about it which
is scary is that in a world of
exponential growth
it's think about tech companies so we
lit we are already with tech in a world
of exponential growth
and look at google look at facebook
yeah once you have enough i think in
english you call it velocity
like you are number one and you gonna
stay look at apple
and you dominate the market so
exponential growth
is actually fostering monopolies yeah
so and the same what we see on companies
and coming back to money printing we see
i think
on on nations or regions that
we are living in a world where if one
nation
for some years is practically ahead
it might be that someone they they can
never be
um they will always be number one so if
china is the first one
to really develop a aii properly if
china would be the first one
to get a quantum computer if china is
gonna first one to really
be ahead ten years in space tag yeah so
there are
certain innovations if you are ahead
you're gonna cement your number one
status and game over
at least for a very long time so why i'm
saying that like
what happens in a bubble what we i don't
even know if i don't want to say if we
have a bubble on the stock but what i
want to say is
we definitely have i think we all agree
on that we have a time
of intense money printing of monetary
inflation of
asset price inflation so you can make
fun of it now that sort of
money is pressed pressure into the
system and like
young people whatever trade on robin
hood up and down
but the truth is even if you take game
stop out or whatever yeah i don't want
to make an argument progress
a part of that money is going in
innovation
and actually a lot so at the moment
thanks to the bubble a lot of innovation
is financed so if you think what money
printing does
it takes away from the capital from from
the ones who are savers who are savers
are actually
forgive me but the older people yeah
and they took a lot out of the world
already and you give it to the younger
people so the younger people
might make stupid stuff right but
overall they actually finance smart
stuff look at what is
working in the stock market climate tech
because they care about climate tech
yeah everything they care about all
these story stocks is working
and yes there might be some stupid ones
but the money is flowing
into a lot of good stuff which actually
if we lucky
cements the technological leadership of
the us because
i i say that way and you're gonna like
it like i rather
trust a 16 year old kid to make right
allocation decision than the government
yeah so before the government tries to
do innovation which
never really works yeah i rather want to
have
a lot of money pressed in the system and
a lot of investors
retail and institutional push that money
into innovation because i think we have
to succeed because
one thing and i don't want to say
anything against china with a lot of
discussion but like
i like to live in the western world and
actually
many i think europe and i i wanna i
think
the world with all the sort of bad stuff
what you can say
about the west yeah it's actually the
place where most people want to live
yeah and so i want the west to succeed
but if you look again into history
always the dominating economic
superpower
became also the dominating political
power
but also also like not just
setting the agenda thing yeah so so so i
i desperately want the america to get
sort of succeed in that and i think
money printing might be the smartest way
to do it so
i would just go on printing just because
we need
we can't lose in a time of exponential
growth we can't lose out on innovation
right it's it's so crazy so just keep
printing the money which oddly devalues
it at some level but at the same time
allows young people to just keep pumping
it into all the cool new things and then
hopefully that did not win it's a lot of
but
there will be good companies at the end
and again the price is paid by older
people who have savings
but i don't want to say anything i don't
know how to say nice in english but if
you're like 80 you're not gonna matter
in 50 years
most like i'm very optimistic despite
all the longevity stuff yeah despite all
the longevity so
so it's kind of like i like to see this
money printing
as kind of almost uh 50 100 inheritance
tax because you take it away
from the people who gonna leave this
planet in the next
20 30 years and you give it to the
younger people and their future and
that's what we all want by the way
again that that's what we where we could
merge like left and right like climate
change is a problem
the question is just do we change it by
i don't know standing on the street or
do we change it with technology with
real innovation
with going to renewable energy but
making that even way more efficient
getting fusion finally running i have a
very cool investment there
like it will work out the next 10 years
if you get fusion running forget about
solar then the thing is fusion like so
but tech will save the world not kill it
we just need to
embrace it tech will save the world not
kill it well i love
i love that you're positive for the
future and that you want to bring
everyone with you because you usually
don't really
hear the tech people talking about that
and i should say that i know that you're
a wise investor because you also did
invest in locals which
i hope makes you more money than your
mushrooms and longevity
and everything else that is my hope for
so um by the way i think because i was
an only child
so i i always learned i need to be nice
to other people to have friends to play
with yeah
and no no success i mean at least this
is my unit like
you don't want to have success without
friends succeeding and on a bigger
picture you don't
want to go i mean one of my big worries
is actually and i
mean i know they're watching but like my
parents are a good example because i
discuss a lot like day 70 i'm like okay
they
i need to really hurry up yeah like but
they don't even want all that stuff
that's one of these good examples where
i have all these discussions
if i had certain things and some things
are available already they don't want to
use and because they're like no this is
natural i'm like no
people told us since thousands of years
this is natural that we age
it's just a story we told ourselves
because we couldn't prevent it like
anyway so but like i want to take the
people with me because i think that's
i mean that's maybe the psychedelic
right it may maybe one last sentence i
have
one i have one cliche it's very very
cheesy but i think it actually
summarizes happiness very well so i was
thinking
like what um what makes people happy
yeah
overall and when i'm happy i don't mean
that giggly like in the moment but like
really like the um
content yeah yeah exactly wise assembly
so
so i think you need three things you
need any form of faith
i touched it already a bit but like and
by the way coming again back to
why because it's fear and trauma and
the biggest fear we all have and we
don't admit
is that either our we either use that
we die we could die or i could die but
even worse is
actually that other people you love
could die so i'm permanently terrified
that some of my parents will die
yeah and everybody is
is terrified that children could happen
happen something to children to your
partner to
to your parents whatever so and and this
is like a permanently
trauma or permanently nagging fear
and and religion
again don't argue if it's real or not
but if you believe
in something which is a little more than
this world
it takes a little bit away this sort of
nagging fear of
losing people for good yeah so then the
second thing you need
is like you need purpose so people want
to know why they're here they want to be
needed they want to be included
and the third is love it's very cheesy
but like you
need we we are pack animals like we need
family we need but we also need love in
a wider circle we need a good
environment we would
friendship whatever so unfortunately
coming back on the whole
development all these three things in
the world we live in
are actually dissolved a bit so faith is
on a record decline
um purpose kind of as well because i
told you like most people
feel that their their um job might not
be there anymore in in
in 10 years and i also love in a certain
way
i don't want to make the pitch because
as you know and i'm gay myself but like
because we dissolving in record speed
um sort of things which give us in a
certain way how is an english hall like
give us a
like family systems but also communities
it's not just about who you love like
it's about
the community like when i grew up like
there was like a school club for
everything like
that so any any of these three things
which make our
actually mind happy is on decline and
the good thing is if i come back
psychedelics give you back of that they
give you back faith
spirituality they give you back purpose
because they show you hey
this is what you really want even if
you're 60 whatever you can do that
and they give you back most important
love and connection to
close people and the world so so i think
that's the formula everybody should
refer without psychedelics i think it's
just a very good
tool for that to hold on to christian
where can i send people
to find out more about you i feel like a
lot of people are gonna you just we just
really scratched the surface on all this
we just do another another i love it i
love to talk like that's like i i'm
admitting that i love
uh talking about this stuff so uh we can
do another one or whatever
yeah but where can i send people to you
have a newsletter
is there a way to where can they sign up
no it's just for close friends because
they're very politically impossible
no what extent do you mean like a
website or like what do you mean sent to
you like
where if they want to find out more
about you and what you're doing well on
meaning on my uh the website of my my
family offices are pyron
a p e i r o n and then
um minus investments.com
or go on a thai like uh this is really
worth checking out so at thais
the the psychedelic company is
definitely the coolest company
i've built so far um i hopefully have
100 years to come and build some more
but like
yeah but like we stock market listed now
so uh there's a lot of information out
there
uh actually twitter i i sort of wrote
to your twitter it's a love and hate
thing although i think it's very
exciting
people need more love it's just like i
don't know why
yeah people's all-star there so linkedin
is a little bit more friendly like sora
yeah i should have realized that i'm on
a very special newsletter that's not the
public
newsletter now i'm even more honored of
a
very small group of people friends
christian i really i really love this
i i would love to trip with you sometime
we're gonna we're gonna have to do that
so i hope to see you
soon we're gonna go to the caribbean i'm
a great gentleman
do you act as a shaman too i don't know
if i want to go
here on a public like um are we gonna
set it up somewhere
we'll figure out something okay all
right it was great seeing you like i'm
uh yeah uh but i think i have compassion
a bit so and this is a good starting
point for tripping together
nice all right sounds good if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about
tech instead of non-stop yelling check
out our tech playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell